welcome to another episode of not too
deep with me your host grace and Helbig
the first today we have an amazing
comedian host wrestling enthusiast tiny
toy collector person it's Jeff dye with
us on this episode of not too deep we
talked about a lot of things mostly I
guess that I mean to him
so I have some thinking to do about my
own behavior but in the meantime enjoy
this episode of not too deep with Jeff
time OkCupid is the only dating app that
finds you someone based on who you are
and what you're into answer fun
questions and meet someone who shares
your deep love or loathing of pineapple
on pizza or commiserate on your views of
the current state of the world the
OkCupid app has awesome people like you
who are into what you're into download
the free OkCupid app today let's not be
deep not deep also else do your away
from any jokes whatsoever the new brand
for not 2019 Jeff died thank you for
being here thanks for having done with
the place thank you you like what I've
done with my producers place I sort of
started doing this on some podcast in
the past but I decided that I'm gonna
start opening up every podcast in 2019
with this question for every guest ok
what is your deal um I feel like a dog
I'm very much a dog I'm nice I'm
friendly I'm annoying I'm not that
bright but if I bother you just push me
away I'll go bother someone else
alright I mean and also on planes you're
enjoyable yeah people are happy to sit
when the dog wants a little attention
too much then you put on your headphones
ya know because dogs recognize boots
no well the owner would go ahead yeah
I'm saying mm-hmm the owner would be
like oh he doesn't want to be bothered
by let's talk about planes you travel
amen
yes you are on the road tons yes
what's your I guess like what's my deal
follow-up question - what's your deal
miss what is your deal no what's your
worst plane experience if you've ever
had one oh it's gonna say no it's gonna
sound like oh that's your worst problem
right but it still affects me I still
haven't let go of it so I'm aware that I
shouldn't let this bother me but it's -
the story yeah yeah just still bothers
mhm I likes I fly it always in the first
flight
I'm always on a 5 a.m. at 6 a.m. I just
want out because I'd rather sleep on a
plane then miss a flight uh what I don't
want to like waste my stuff time but if
I'm already gonna be asleep in a bed
might as well do it on a plane ok so
that's my logic I get more of my life
free if I just sleep on a plane instead
of a bed so I'm getting that so I like
the window seat so I get on the airplane
and there's already a lady in my window
seat and she's asleep she's got like a
thing over her face you just kind of
think most humans would just let that go
they would say ok I guess I don't know
what to do maybe I'll sit in the seat
next to it like next to the person
whatever it's a she well sit and seat
next to my seat yeah yeah that's what it
came from is a seat and so then I didn't
know what to do so just kind of like sat
down so I didn't know such a sat down
mhm and then a different lady came I was
like hey I think you're in my seat and I
said oh well she's in my seat
I don't know what to do and she's like
out she's like it was sleep so I finally
just could find a fight and I go hey I
think she's in my seat yeah and oh no I
didn't do that so sorry I tapped her say
hey I think um I see she sit right there
I'm already asleep Oh sounds super fun
man I was like there's very rare moments
were like wait a minute I'm a grown
and I shouldn't have to do that I'm in
addition to her an adult but as my mom
is like like very few moments right step
back and go yeah I didn't have to take
that but what I did is I sat in her seat
like a punk I just sat there and then
the flight attendant came that was
whatever and then I go you know what I'm
gonna tell because we haven't even taken
off their eyes I'm gonna snitch so I go
she's in my seat
I'm the window seat and she's in my seat
uh-huh and and the lady and maybe
because for whatever reason I'm
speculating that they might be the same
race the lady goes she says she's
already asleep just sit here took her
side and made me sit in her seat how
long was the flight I don't know I don't
remember this is years ago I mean that
chivalry is not was it Lisa what a spin
no it was a middle so you know the
middle Wow lame yeah but you're right
that is your worst good but it just like
I'd like in my mind is like why couldn't
if someone who's been like hey that's
the seat you got mm-hmm you can have
your seat that you paid for what would
you do if the roles were reversed if you
accidentally took someone C and you
fellas there was no accident crazy
course you you always take the side
story pranking someone in I mean can you
imagine if that's your mo being like I
got a middle seat but what if I get on
the plane first I'm just gonna take the
[ __ ] window and pretend I took a
valium and pass the [ __ ] out and then no
one can touch me
well that's what's probably I think that
that is uh I don't this is gonna get too
deep I think that's the problem with
life is is when people go oh I I have no
interest in what other people want I
have no interest in this well I just
want a window seat and some cell phones
you know and then yeah because that's
exactly how I feel about people that
just sort of hover into a line and then
become ahead of you and I and I'm so
non-confrontational that I'll just let
them do it but I will non-stop just
stare them down the whole time
no I see what's happening and you see
that I see what's happening is I got
change anything so I'm gonna say
anything but like how do you live the
rest of your life how do you go on place
for people just forget how lines works
da da is the only other place that I've
recently learned is also a place where
people forget what lines are I had a
similar ish experience except it was the
opposite no I was at the DMV and this
old woman that you know she was a for
lack of a better term oh I thought she
was with another group of people turn
there's no groups of people that DMV
everyone is an individual like hero
trying to make it through this like
Zelda st. if you go with your friend of
the team in the worst place everywhere
no one wants to be will make it fun this
woman just started loudly talking at
this other woman who obviously was non
confrontational and just like absorbed
whatever she was talking about and
that's how she cut in line is that she
made everyone else think that she was
friends with this woman and that this
woman had been holding her spot and I
was like it's not worth my time but this
old woman has a gimmick and she's
sticking to it and I respect that sort
of and I kind of loved watching this
other woman just have to take it on and
look around and just be like I don't
know her I don't respect that at all
anyway I got a really great DMV photo
you're confusing evil with clever
you go oh wow you know what at least she
was smart
she's deceptive yourself on other
people's good with I'll talk to my
therapist this week about my ability to
confuse liars
yeah very smart people throw a loophole
they should you know like wow he's smart
okay so one you've done a million things
which is very fun to talk about what's
the thing that you hate talking about
the most that you've ever done I don't
mind talking about any of it I guess
there's a show called nuts right now I
was like is it numb nuts
well actually here's the thing I love
talking about the most and hate when
people ask me about the most which is I
know that sounds contradicting I love
Bigfoot so much and I could talk about
Bigfoot for hours and hours and hours
like I'm obsessed yes not mythical it's
just a bipedal hominid in the woods it's
great they walk upright is they're
awesome so I love talking my Bigfoot the
problem is that it's in my bio it says
like Bigfoot enthusiast because I
thought that would be real cheeky to put
in my bio but whenever I go do like
morning television to promote comedy
shows that'd be fun yeah I see that
you're a Bigfoot enthusiast and then I
have to be like you know I take is very
that's it so I hate it when they ask me
about it because I do like talking about
it but when they think it's like this
fun thing to bring oh I'm with you I was
in the Miss New Jersey pageant when I
was in college and I also did pole vault
when I was in high school and somehow
people found out and put on my Wikipedia
page and it's the only thing that gets
brought up in interviews ever whether I
go to any place and it's the worst thing
that could be like yes yes both of these
things are just so you used to be an
athlete and in beauty pageants and now
you're silly yeah can you imagine and
that's that please come to my show
um okay what is well you've done a
billion prank show yeah I love pranks
were you into pranks before you got the
hosting gig for these prank shows yes
much so very much so I think like I like
the prank because it's fun and you're
usually doing it to like have a good
time but it's also a little mischievous
so that's what I like about it is you're
kind of doing something you know I hate
pranks yes well you generally with the
exception of my show money from
strangers you generally are pranking
people you love or someone like it's
like a goof I know and also not to put
youtubers in a box but there's a lot of
pranks on YouTube that I don't cannot
into that genre on you - yeah weird like
I just just let my girlfriend the face
with flower while she was asleep
aren't we wild don't worry she'll get me
back by putting a roach in my underwear
it's like this is not a prank you guys
are just mean yeah youtuber pranks just
actually ruin like pedestrians lives
because they don't know that they're
part of a YouTube prank they just
remember that they saw something
horrific on the street happen and that's
the part I hate the most the innocent
people that as a by-product have to go
on with the rest of their day and
pretend that that but also like I do
there's a spectrum of pranks and I enjoy
like a playful fun goof I'm scaring
someone or something like that that's
really funny to me what's the worst
prank that's ever been pulled on you if
there has been one that's a good it
wouldn't seem very clever to you it
would I'm very guarded telling you
things you're on not too deep the
loosest podcast the award-winning dreamy
award-winning podcast before you're very
cool and your venue your hip to the
Internet you oh you're a very attractive
woman so we can you tell someone
something usually they guys Jeff's a
silly guy you just tend to make fun of
everything I said no and I'm like oh did
I say a word wrong oh good is my shirt
not hip enough like
like this anymore so I hesitate to tell
you something you're gonna go that's not
a good tale is really indicative of
where my years good friends do have like
yeah punch up the stories or feel like
it's got to be hip it's not a good prank
but you're the one that's feeling
negative about that maybe I'm projecting
I welcome you into a safe space you can
tell us stories and we get to
authentically react to them well okay
then I guess I was just questioning if
it is a safe space okay so it's not a
great prank but if we were like in fifth
grade and it's is it was so gross these
kids came up to me and they're my
friends and they go dude have you had
the new Pepsi one or whatever the new
product was Coke Zero or whatever this
thing was and they go it tastes exactly
like coca-cola and I was like no dude
those always tastes different and gross
and weird he goes no but this one I
think they screwed up and they put the
wrong label on or something and when I
drank it it was obviously had like
cheese and all this like crap they just
found on the lunchroom table and so I
went just like I'm done didn't feel it
or shake and then spewed like everywhere
on the on the lunchroom table that's
definitely the worst prank does anyone
the buildup sounded like an actual like
Pepsi commercial you know I stopped
hanging out with those guys name name
you look at my friends circle now
they're not in it it was a mat root
sugar okay I know him well well know him
now
yeah seek him out yeah he's not a public
figure but Matt root singer if I ever
see you again
dot dot dot yeah all right on that no
we're gonna take a quick break and we'll
get back we're gonna talk about your
Terry Bradshaw's actual bromance yeah
which is nice it sounds sexual oh that's
very sweet romance is the word that it's
fun you have a very sweet relationship
with an adult man yeah support for
today's show comes from third love using
millions of real women's measurements
third love designs its bras with breast
size and shape in mind for an impeccable
fit an incredible feel just answer a few
simple questions from third loves fit
finder quiz to find your perfect fit
third love offers double the number of
sizes that most brands offer cups a
through H bands up to forty a and with
lightweight memory foam cups straps that
won't slip and tagless labels you'll
want to wear these soft and breathable
bras and underwear every day especially
the new cotton t-shirt bras and
underwear but thanks to the 100% fit
guarantee returns and exchanges are free
and easy guys have said this before I'm
a sports bra enthusiast through and
through
when third love sent me some of their
bras I have been fully converted third
love knows there's a perfect bra for
everyone so right now they're offering
you beautiful listeners 15% off your
first order go to 3rd love.com slash
grace now to find your perfect fitting
bra and get 15% off your first purchase
that's third love.com slash grace for
15% off today okay yes better late than
ever describe this to people that don't
know because I have tried to wrap my
brain around this and it's the craziest
seeming TV show of all time yeah it's
it's a travel show for really famous old
guys so it's kind of like grumpy old man
meets like I don't know what well that's
a joke yeah you're the tour organizer
and suitcase holder for senior male
celebs well it's Terry Bradshaw
Henry Winkler William Shatner and George
Foreman and they're on the adventure of
a life they're trying to travel the
world now that they've done they're kind
of done with their work in a way and
like bucket list yeah and yeah that's a
good way to put it and so they just want
to go see the world and go to places
they've never been or places that they
didn't get to spend much time and when
they had to work there yeah and enjoy
themselves
I represent like if you have a viewer
yeah usually compared to them yeah like
if the if the viewers like I wonder what
it'd be like to travel with them you
kind of get a witness it threw me I'm
like the unknown when he says something
silly ago you know like when they're
being such silly old men I get to go you
know I represent that you roll your eyes
more than they do yeah I screw things up
more than anybody and you guys went to
Asia Asia was season one yeah we went to
Europe yeah and then Europe in Africa oh
god that it just seems cumbersome but
it's also NBC they're like taking care
of us the pain is impatient sort of okay
they had like a few people that are
considering and then my boss at NBC just
goes Jeff Dodds gonna be that and they
were like cuz he's the highest up at NBC
say they were like we have to but I just
went to Henry Winkler's house and had
tea with him and that Henry's like yeah
I like that guy he's the guy so way more
Winnetou casting the for men than me I
just got to have T it I couldn't believe
it I was like I'm going to Henry
Winkler's house and they're like yeah
here's his address I was like what do I
do
to talk to him ours was only having tea
with it was really amazing this is a
beautiful home his wife came to us as
were chatting up with her hit a
three-legged dog running around the
living room nice I was working to keep
coming up you want more lemon pound cake
and as like where am I
it was such a delight but we bonded a
lot cuz he has dyslexia I have dyslexia
he had a lot of learning things she had
a lot of issues with his parents I have
issues my parents so there was a lot we
had a lot in common
to relate to yes nice that's super dice
how has it been actually traveling with
them great yeah yeah they're so they're
all really fun and you and Terry are
really good friends now I think we get
along the best cuz and this sucks that I
would believe this but I think we just
have the most in common so that it's
just easier to get along I wish that I
didn't suck that you would believe that
we should be able to click really well
with people that you have nothing in
common with to reason like people relate
to each other yes they have things in
common but I don't want to just like
people who are like me cuz you hate
yourself so you want to do so much just
like me so I love him like that dot of
people that aren't like me
great sure I mean there's a whole gamut
there's a whole spectrum but it's also
ok to admit that you like someone that's
exactly like oh yeah he's just like an
old version of me I feel like he's very
playful and silly he's always goofing
off like yeah I spent the last 3
Christmases the last 3 Thanksgiving last
3 yeah oh and how has it been it's funny
he lives on this big ranch where there's
all these animals literally I feel like
I saw photos and videos over the
holidays it seems like he has an
adoption facility he's like 12 dogs that
seems illegal but I guess in Texas you
have like 300 acre ranch you can
nobodies policing have you been to a dog
shelter they're begging you to take like
you want this you're like yeah you gonna
kill it no all right now I have a dog
that's always trust me I know
so I would Terry comes in there just
give them a little place what other
animals does he have he has like
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
horses that's his main animal oh really
yeah that's how he makes all of his
money he like breeds them and shows on
does he race them hey guys I'll get into
like deep conversation I know nothing
about horses so whenever I try to limp
in on a horse conversation they all look
at me like why is the boy trying to
don't know anything I'm like how many
horses you got no I don't ask someone
that was like why and he goes because
that's like asking how much money you
have in your bank account
asking you a horse question have you
learned any of the names any of the
voices cuz that seems to be the funniest
thing about horses to me is like the
ridiculous names that they have no I
don't know he has a donkey named horse
or named snoop dunk which i think is
great appropriate and he's got a bunch
of cows there's a ton of cows up there
he's got some scent and tall cattle he's
got a bunch of bulls my favorite is he
has a barn of pigs and I love pigs I
don't eat meat because I met a pig like
11 years ago kindergarteners level of
education oh really that's what people
say about pigs that they're smarter than
dogs they're so sweet I love pigs that's
why I don't touch me because of this one
pig but anyways he has a whole bar full
of pigs and we go back to tell us about
the one pig that made you stop eating
yeah almost with a girl we went to like
a winery and there was this little pig
running around and they're all drinking
wine and gossiping and being like and
you were laser focus on this so I'm
playing with the pig and the guy that's
like teaching them about wine and all
this stuff in the winery he saw that I
was more interesting the pigs he goes
yeah that pig lives here is you know
whatever friend of ours and I was like
man he seems like real smart he goes
yeah they're very smart so then as we
when I went back to the table to pretend
like I was an adult again and drink wine
with everyone think yeah it kept nudging
me and I was like what's going and he
goes he remembers you like he knows that
you're the one that was playing with him
so whatever I gots nice so I'm playing
with him under the table and then I
ignore him and I'm looking at the girls
again and then he put his chin on my
knee
though say my dog you just like rest and
I was like oh never again never will I
can eat fake pork you know he's so a
pork order but Terry is a barn full of
pigs and he won't go in there because
they will all be slaughtered and given
away any emotional time because he will
when he donates that meet the it's like
some sort of charity where he raises the
pigs and then gives all the meat to this
charity that's ya know I watched a
couple different like documentaries
about like
raising pigs with like respect to be
slaughter but like in like the most like
giving them the best lives they can well
if they die of old age I support that
you know he's got grey beard and the
cane he passed away yeah we can cut them
up okay yoga question mark is the
question I have for you you love you I
love oh yeah how long have you been into
that I like 10 years how did that happen
a girl this is fantastic and then long
after that person's gone I'm still into
it oh that's great yeah I love you do
you like it rather die enjoy no it's
it's something I should enjoy I know
that eventually I plenty of time to
enjoy it I'm making yourself do you know
I should just I call it just you know
fancy stretching and I have gone in
peaks and valleys in my life of dabbling
with fancy stretching and I know
eventually I need to because I got bad
knees you don't know what hate you
calling it fancy stretching every
dependency it's very slow for your mind
then your body I know and that's
probably where I'm at that I can't enjoy
it's too slow it gives me too much time
to think about my thoughts so well have
you there's lots of yoga that I am I
kind of do back and forth
yeah there's it's called yoga sculpt so
you have like light weights and it's
very fast-paced and it's a to be fair
it's very vain like that's more for your
body like just trying trying to be like
oh it's the new year like I want to like
sweat it all yoga is doing like YouTube
like 10-minute high-intensity yoga yeah
yeah and that's the only to do it on
YouTube ever heard of it yeah but not
for yoga dingdong gallery studio where
there's other humans they entered
connects and I don't have to pay $90 a
money she can't afford yoga I don't like
the energy of people like when I work
out I like to be in a very isolated
space that's why I run that's my I like
running - yeah it's very isolated whoo I
got bad knees the Honda running oh ya
know stretching all running yeah I don't
think you don't like you I think you
have a problem with stretching I think I
just want to get to the activity get in
get out and then be done and then feel
bad about it later when my knees hurt
and I can't walk me yeah well I'm so
much in my phone I'm computer and all
that kind of like I kind of yeah I'm too
much when people complain like there are
people are in their phone too much I'm
that guy I'm in my phone way yeah what's
your social media platform go to like
what's the one that you are probably
used to Graham yeah but what I was gonna
say is like I'm in my phone so much that
like Yoga is a nice like it forces me to
be away from my phone so I'm in like a
hot studio around people so I like that
part of it like that's the one time I'm
forcing myself know my best ideas and my
only ideas come from when I'm running or
taking a shower cuz I don't have my
phone in my hand
that's why shower eight hours a day
that's why I run in my shower confusing
my dog hates it it's very weird
what ooh have you ever had to untag
yourself from a photo on social media
almost daily why well because people
will post photos that are old of me like
in a relationship or something I'm like
oh yeah or they'll and they're because
people don't don't know me they're
usually doing it
or it's like someone will see something
very funny like oh this is a funny meme
I want Jeff to see it but I'm not in the
meme it's not like nothing to do I'm
like why would you tag me in this just
maybe text it to me or DM it to me you
don't have to look tag me in it so I
like untagging myself on that and then
also I have like OCD so I like the way
my
looks like your page yeah when you like
scroll up and like look through it's
called an Instagram theme Instagram
aesthetic Instagram this is me showing
my age going what is I call them people
have like an actual theme that I have
never been able to actually figure out
that it yeah yeah and I like it to look
a certain way so it just looks weird I
look sowhat's how would you describe how
your Instagram looks to someone that's
never seen it
well my this is you're gonna think I'm
so lame
no this is I'm a social-media influencer
I need hot tips on how to get worse now
we can get more likes because of it but
my my goal with my Instagram page is I
always I want it to look like I'm
smiling I want to be smiling a lot and I
also want it to be people I don't want
photos of things or places as much as it
should when I when you scroll down wine
you're like look he's happy and he loves
people and so it's my friends it's
people I work with I think that's why so
much more sincere than most people's
themes are like red and that's what's
important to me that's a very sweet
theme and you do it well what's your
like MO when you wake up in the morning
of like how do you post things like how
do you go through your social media I
don't post that often I maybe I do bite
my tongue I think I post on my story a
lot you both it's only been fascinating
because you were coming on here so I was
stalking your whole Instagram and it was
like you posting bursts of threes right
you post like three photos out of
nowhere once a day and then that's it
and I was like this is an interesting
way to Alice there's really no strategy
if I didn't know something know like
it's not like it's working you've seen
my eyes it's not like I'm like yeah it's
all part of my part of the 200 likes
ever like it's not like
there's no grandiose plan you also
tagged yourself and all your photos
right so that if you see if you look at
tagged photos is that bad do people not
do that generally no no I I didn't know
if that was it I don't know that because
I figure people are looking for me
they'll find your page and then they'll
see all your photos and then they can
see your tagged photos
weird welcome to my TED talk about
Instagram no I didn't know if that was a
thing I was like should I be tagging
myself and all my photos so people can
find them because Instagram changes
every but also a village what's your
least favorite form of social media
least favorite form of social media
would be Twitter but I have to do it I
feel like I have to do it yeah yeah
because well I'll tell you like oh do
you have anyone that you hate follow on
Twitter that you love follow on Twitter
oh yeah okay best follow on Twitter is
Randy Quaid okay the best Twitter
follower of all time Wow also they used
to be an NBA player named Chris Kaman
well he's he's just not in the NBA
anymore but maybe he is I don't know he
was a clipper and he's is big like crazy
kind of looks like a bald Bigfoot you
know just like this big guy even a
hairless one it would play for the
Clippers and he's this big but also look
him up Chris Kaman just this big guy
right and he's a redneck and so he'd be
playing like it let's say the Clippers
are playing the Hawks he would post a
photo of him like with a dead hawk that
he liked playing the Hawks tonight and
you're like oh my god he's just showing
like that's definitely against the law -
you can't just like kill a hawk I mean
he did it for the Bobcats he's like
holding up a dead Bobcat lady animals
he's a big redneck and he like grew up
in somewhere he's and he's got like camo
overalls like in the picture so weird I
mean that is also a specific aesthetic
also Jose Canseco is great because he'll
get the fights with his wife and just
tweet about it like this dumb B word and
he'll put like photos of her that are
really in a pro
and then the next morning he'll delete
it all and then be like with the love of
my life I can't imagine anything without
her like she just posts all these
flare-ups okay well we're gonna take a
break and on this break I'm gonna go
follow a Jose Canseco he's important to
me now we'll be right back with your
questions for Jeff day I'm not too deep
want to save money save the planet and
look good doing it it doesn't get any
better then thread up thread up is the
largest online consignment store where
you can shop high-quality pieces for up
to 90% off estimated retail they have
over 35,000 brands ranging from Gap to
Gucci with thousands of new items added
every day you can find a coach purse for
$10 an anthropology dress for six
dollars and a Lululemon tank for $10
that's insane I know that's insane yeah
if you go to thread up comm slash grace
today you'll also get an extra 30% off
your first order it's super easy and fun
to shop save your sizes your favorite
brands and filter for exactly what you
want it's the comfort of shopping online
with the insane deals of thrifting look
good and do good this year with thread
up so go to thread up comm slash grace
for an extra 30% off your first order
that's th our e-d-u p.com slash grace
thread up comm such grace for 30% off
today terms of play today's not too deep
is brought to you by hum-hum nutrition
is all about making you look and feel
your best each specific supplement packs
a combo of potent ingredients designed
for specific games like clearer skin
boosted energy fuller hair and is backed
by clinical results hum focuses on
preventing concerns and long-term care
and repair not damage control and
covering up their inside out approach to
beauty goes beyond skin care regimen
alone to give you great results hums
products are sustainably sourced not GMO
and free of soy gluten artificial colors
and preservatives
plus lots of vegan options try
supplements like the daily cleanse hair
sweet hair growth gummies uber energy
and more if you aren't sure what you
need go to home nutrition comm slash get
underscore started to take a quiz and
get personalized recommendations from
hums team of registered dieticians to
make things even easier hama offers a
monthly vitamin subscription that's
affordable flexible and convenient I
mean hair sweet hair growth gummies one
you know I love a gummy vitamin two you
know I need to grow my hair rocks my
extensions have ravished my scalp
uncontrollably so three this is my
best-case scenario I'm all for it I'm
all for uber energy Oh because I am
always tired I need you to be awake to
record these podcasts right so I started
taking an uber energy and I'm really
enjoying it like we said go to hum
nutrition calm slash get underscore
started for your personalized
recommendations and get 20% off your
purchase with code grace that's home
nutrition comm slash get underscore
started and code grace deep we're gonna
get into these Twitter questions but I'm
gonna ask you the two questions asked
every single guest that's on the podcast
before we get into those so first is who
alive or dead would you most want to
throw cold spaghetti at oh no no no
necessarily well they're probably not
gonna like it right it depends on the
person yeah I guess some freak that you
don't have to explain to the audience
right now if there's not many people I
have ever thought about throwing cold
spaghetti yeah that is the general
that's why it's so silly fun question I
would probably throw honest cold
spaghetti mmm-hmm at I feel like Terry
would love it I'm just gonna throw that
out there I don't know him as a human
but seeing your relationship you may
find it kind of you know sweet no I ask
what other people have answered
uh what do you what is your answer it's
a full spectrum and it changes day by
day okay like throw cold spaghetti I'm
gonna see right now the pig that that
wineries that you met hmm I hope you
like that be the greatest you might like
if you like to rest your chin he's like
why did she bring cold spaghetti to this
whiner
hey no one checked my pocket I would
probably throw cold spaghetti we can
come back this is tough man all right so
don't you deep is it a hard-hitting
question I know that's the question the
other question is every single guest is
to tell us your worst pants [ __ ]
story or close call you can only use
three words or three small phrases or a
mix of the two
looks um mine is college jogging front
lawn Wow Oh Hollywood video lying lying
yeah he's gonna say like horrible stank
you know what a world and there's no
follow-up questions that's really paints
a horrible stank you okay now it's
getting to do some Twitter questions
okay yeah well someone just asked who's
your favorite person on Twitter but I
think you've already answered that you
can elaborate if you think of anyone
else but someone's no what's your worst
stand-up story I once opened for a band
and I wasn't good at comedy yet to be
honest I got so I don't know why people
ever booked stand-ups to open for band
never works
I don't I've heard horror stories some
other stand-ups that have the exact same
scenario
and but we just like money so we're like
I we got a do that's all it is we know
it's gonna be a nightmare they hope it's
not gonna be a nightmare and then we get
paid and we did you try at home what was
so what's this snares a little different
because I wasn't getting paid I was like
not a successful comedian yet but I had
a friend had this really great Brant
band in Seattle and I hadn't seen him
much and they were like doing pretty
good they're growing pretty big and then
they're like hey we're playing this like
venue and I go hey can me and some
friends come no can I have tickets he
goes yeah dude and I just talked to my
manager do you want to open for us do
you want to do your stand-up in front of
our show and I said no horrible idea we
just want to come and support your band
and he goes there's all text it's not
like on the phone he's like oh well he
said you know he really wants you to do
stand-up in front of the thing and then
I was like I know yeah I'm not gonna do
this then he came back with a text like
probably 20 minutes later hey you gonna
have free tickets to the show you can
have a bar tab and we'll give you $200
if you open for us how old were you at
this time wasn't my 20s but I was like
real new at comedy and I had probably
negative 400 dollars in my bank account
so this you're making money yeah I was
living in a Volkswagen Jetta like I
didn't have a home I lived in the
backseat of a car I am in no position to
turn down $200 cash and a free bar tab
without it so I did it
and it was a nightmare it was so bad
that years after that in Seattle when
people be like hey I've seen you do
comedy before I go where thank god oh
hey nice to meet you okay because I was
I'm so psychologically devastated by
that gig what was the style of music
that the band they were like what like
if Incubus wasn't famous you know it was
like you know Cuba's no I they're very
famous that's I'm just saying like I'm
saying oh no I don't think I don't think
people are going to a you know Incubus
esque
concert going I hope I can giggle before
it and also like if anyone knows my
comedy if you don't like I spend my act
is like 80% smiling 20% jokes
birds and kitty cats like I'm saying
like nobody's going to watch me be like
well it's only gone up from there
someone's know your favorite WWE moment
of all time I don't have any favorite
moments I know that's weird but I do
think like just like the stone-cold like
era or like when I was a little boy I
liked Razor Ramon I don't know like I
can't think of any matches or anything
that were like these big holy [ __ ]
moments yeah but I like it all what
match would you want to see now I want
to match anyone out of retirement
anyone that's dead anyone yeah braun
strowman who hates me now I didn't
realize how I had for those of you that
don't know I was on Jeff Ty's podcast
and you said he looked like a low-rent
wait no he looked like a budget cast
member of rent and he tweeted at you
about it and I got scared
you caught the biggest guy in WME I said
I hate him so much
hey hey hey I can't was the quote I
think hate hate hate I can't I said very
very black-and-white definitively that I
did not like him Russell's are used to
that though like you're talking about
its character but that's like a that's a
compliment in a way there's like that's
part of what they go for they're either
beloved or hated yeah some of those guys
love being hated mm-hmm and some of them
are just humans that I shouldn't say bad
feelings about a beautiful woman that's
famous San Shi Oh real knowledge or WWE
just has like a basic surface level and
goes I don't like him he's boring
I don't like his outfit and he has no
say on what he has to wear no although
it like to just piggyback on that I said
all I care you're like
he's big and I said yeah agreed
should be kind of annoyed with me I'm
surprised replied to it at all okay so
your dream matches him
okay braun strowman mm-hmm vs diesel oh
then Kevin Nash and he kills Jay Z's
David Ison Mark Ruffalo to wrestle
anyone that's a good match yeah if he
comes out in tiny Hulk gear I was love
at least Cogan with his tag-team partner
Brooke Hogan uh-huh versus tag-team
partner Charlotte oh wow it's called
daddy issues I would be glued to the
screen
we all have does okay what or what
someone to know how did you get obsessed
with WWE oh I think they're asking you
that uh-huh no no this is at Jeff die I
read that one and I thought they were
talking to me I thought they're tiny I
mean no you can refuse to answer if you
don't know I just a kid when I was a
little kid I was like actually you know
that bevy of toy collection that's
behind me in my room yeah if you guys
don't know please go check out his
podcast because it is um it's
interesting to have a conversation with
you just surrounded by a fever dream of
trinkets literally you have so many
collectibles and you just bring people
into this room of collectibles and
they're ready now here we go let's talk
for now in my youth welcome to my
teenage bedroom no there's a bunch of
these toys I remember I went to this
kid's house that named Eric Barron it's
really sweet kid my mom and dad he's a
huge fan of the podcast
well me hope he isn't me and Eric both
didn't have any friends at school and so
our parents like made us hang out with
each other and so what this house it's
true like I guess we're friends Nana cuz
nobody else wants us and he had those
exact toys that are behind me on the
ground and I'm so like captivated by him
was like wow these are really cool what
is this
and because it's wrestling and I think
what's wrestling
he showed me like a magazine and then
literally the next day at his house it
was on oh and we started watching it and
then from then I just became real
obsessed and that's why I'm still like
linked to those toys and weird way and
my childhood no I get it my older
brothers were into like Warhammer and
that sort of thing so my anytime I
walked past my older brother's room it
just smelled like fumes and he was just
painting tiny men and we called him his
tiny men and it was and he's now giving
it to my nephew nephew doesn't know it's
very sweet I was a [ __ ] when I was
younger and I hated it but no you're a
kid I'm trying to be cool like dork
so why am i well my sisters would do
that about wrestling oh yeah like you
know brick fake let's see that's how I
got arrested was my older brother would
watch bushwhackers and I loved my older
brother so we would just do bushwhackers
in the attic room that we should and
then when I was in college that's how
you knew when I was drunk is that I
would just start doing bushwhackers by
myself and all the cool kids that didn't
watch wrestling like she's a nut like
she dances what's a wrestling reference
I didn't believe in understandings I was
just mimicking my older brother in the
whole like childhood there's so many
wrestling questions so let's know if you
could get body-slammed by any wrestler
active or retired who would it be and
why weird question I'd like to be hurt
by which wrestler I mean I guess I'd
like to be hurt by the Ultimate Warrior
yeah yeah use a fun way yeah he's the
best he's the yeah the sweatiest and
also doesn't the craziest GJ he wouldn't
either his promos age turns his back to
the camera on silly it's my favorite
thing anyway like he was on a bevy of
cocaine you like what there's one uh
there's a famous model
anyone who knows wrestling knows what
I'm about to reference but if you
haven't watched wrestling there's a
great clip of the Ultimate Warrior
basically doing a promo to Hulk Hogan
where he describes a terrorist attack
he's a when we're on the plane Hogan I
will go into the cockpit and I will
those pilots will make the ultimate
sacrifice then I will grab the controls
and I
we'll navigate the plane into the
mountain he's like he's gonna kill
everyone don't let him on a plane if it
snows he said you kill the pilot so that
he could take in truck it's insanity and
this is children's morning television
this is a Saturday afternoon yeah this
is live-action cartoons what the things
they got away with is like how are they
showing this to children and it's shaped
who we are oh but I was gonna say my
sister would always pick on me cuz you
said you were a [ __ ] but that's just
what siblings do well no I just refused
my there was a to my older brother and
younger brother loved Magic the
Gathering love Pokemon they loved
Warhammer they loved Dungeons and
Dragons all of that and there was a
store in the mall called like wizards
like Wizards of the East or something
like that and my dad would take us on
Wednesday visitation and my brothers
would go in there and I would sit there
and refused to go people enjoy things I
don't know about I know I was I was
terrible god bless my father for trying
to balance my brothers and myself out
the same interested in I want to go to
Claire's shop with it Claire I wasn't I
was a dork I would never dream of doing
that well my sister would always go on
you know wrestling's fake and I used to
be like I think you're dumb and I was a
boy I was a little kid and I think I
think you're dumb for believing that I'm
dumb enough to think this is real like
I'm aware that it's sergeant and an
Indian got together in a ring to settle
there I know it's fake and in the same
way when you're watching like cheers or
friends I'm not like you know they don't
really friends just actors yeah
everything is a story we have to suspend
Courtney Cox are really good friends in
real life so it is real it's all
happening yeah the documentary Ross and
Rachel together again this is maybe the
weirdest tweet we've ever gotten for not
too deep guests and it's kind of a
visual so apologies to anyone that's
listening to this right now well we can
link to it in the show notes
thank God I don't know it's also put a
link to Wizards of the East my dad with
that store it's called I know exactly
where it was is right next to the Macy's
but the I don't know if it's
tiffani-amber thiessen or this is
actually a photo of this woman okay she
tweeted is Jeff guy married if not does
he like older women doesn't help that I
am also a Seattle native and then I
think she tweeted this selfie of her
which I don't know if this is
tiffani-amber thiessen from Saved by the
Bell
or actually which woman she might be
really flattered that you think that it
could be Tiffany everything what a nice
thing to say yeah she's beautiful but
this is the most direct I'll answer like
no it doesn't help you from Seattle no I
don't want to marry older women but what
a strange approach if you're married and
do you like older women does it help but
I'm also a Seattle native not married no
interest and no interesting getting
married you [ __ ] up my chance to be a
matchmaker sorry
you gotta come a little harder than that
you gave me one option of a lady you
don't even know amy j9m one good for of
course I know some like a sweet lady I
also think that maybe she doesn't know
how Twitter works or dating works for
them that's not how dating starts but
I've never met a girl this way hey you
like older girls I mean you might be
hitch this is my future just so you know
I'm gonna be using Twitter in like ten
years so do not hate on this wonderful
Linda hating yourself out there make
yourself vulnerable yeah now all of a
sudden I'm on your side Amy j9m one
which is probably a bot and this might
be a sex pot who knows okay it's a sex
pot they wouldn't there wouldn't be like
a nice cropped photo of her in front of
a fireplace it would be her boobs and
butt or something like you like older
woman here's my crotch sexbots work I
mean like I'm not sure it's real there's
zero followers and all right I'll follow
just in case it is really
on that note we've reached the end of
the podcast yeah thank you so much for
being here but as a guest and not too
deep we give everyone a very very
special gift and it is fun it's a
personalized fortune cookie just for you
do you can I ask you a question about
fortune cookies a thousand percent yes
when they come to the table mm-hmm I get
this really excited get very excited
when the fortune cookie comes yeah
because I never expecting it I don't eat
this kind of food that often you do you
eat the cookie or do you just break it
up and leave it literally a garbage
disposal sugar even in the smallest bits
which is like a fortune cookie but
garbage monster yeah oh yeah it's
definitely not the way of fortune
cookies normally it's folded in there
like it like some might say that's
exactly what I didn't get one it's just
a gusher someone put a fruit snack in
mine they must have heard I can't read
we know you ordered the Bionic penis
male sex nevermind
we also know you only did it as a
decoration for your house which is
weirder I don't know how you know any of
this won't be shamed I'm allowed to like
whatever I want man or robot yeah no you
have a very beautiful spread in your
house you have very specific aesthetic
I've already gone over and so we're just
letting the audience know that there's
many elements to it I've imagined that
that robot should be treated better at
my home than any sort of pervert who
wants to rough up a robot I will be
tender and a nice treat that robot with
the respect it deserves if it was alive
can I have that a separate clip after we
do this I can people find you your
podcast and whatever you're doing if
they don't already know at Jeff died
tons of tagged photos of me just going
through untag no I honestly don't think
it's bad I feel like you thought it was
bad I just didn't I honestly didn't know
that's not like a concern like almost a
fatherly moment like everybody's been
talking about it iTunes just go to Jeff
dies friendship podcast and when does it
come out it's every Wednesday very cool
and are you doing any I don't know when
this episode will come out in February
for us will you be my birthday February
oh happy birthday anywhere in February
that people can go find you just go to
Jeff dot-com and my whole calendar is
there cuz I don't really yeah and I'm
sure things change last-minute anyway
thank you so much for being here
you guys should go listen to his podcast
I was on an episode a couple weeks ago
it was super fun I talked way more about
wrestling than I ever anticipated
talking about we did I already tell you
that I might have already repeated this
sentence to you but like I thought I'd
take everything you say like oh she
knows what she's talking about
than me I didn't graduate high school
but the but you said like oh you know I
listened to an episode because you know
I was gonna be on it and you were like
it's very like dude heavy it's very bro
II and then I was like no the two bro II
and then she came on and only wanted to
talk about pro wrestling I think I just
got absorbed in the trinkets and the
bros around me that night really way too
bro enough about my life let's talk
about wrestling let's talk about dudes
hittin do feminism fully support it so
we'll see you guys next I wonder that's
sort of Matthews here by toe deep
Oh deep deep want to save money save the
planet and look good doing it it doesn't
get any better than thredUP
the largest online consignment and
thrift store shop over 35,000 brands at
up to 90% off estimated retail go to
thredUP comm / grace for an extra 30%
off your first order that's th our edu
p.com / grace thread up comm / grace for
an extra 30% off today not too deep as a
production of grace helbig incorporated
a producer and directed by Jack ferry
producer and editor Melissa de mons
writing by Diane King post production
sound by Chris Henry and an extra
special thanks to Flula for the theme
music